in honor of having carrots and rice and
you talk about work on optimal growth
engine cited markets right thanks to you
all right thanks yeah yeah all right so
yeah so this is a talk from a paper that
I've been working on with Jen Lian for
he's a student at Cornell so it's
basically looking at to Steve's point
it's it's a pretty high-level macro
model around this issue of like how to
optimally grow it two-sided market so
I'll talk a little about the motivation
and kind of like why we're looking at it
but it's kind of like they're you know
growth like is a very important concern
and a lot of like I work for lyft as
well I'm so I'm on leave from Cornell
and full-time I left and you know all
like rideshare companies have large
growth organizations they spend a lot of
time thinking about like how to grow
supply and demand in the market how to
manage the you know the subsidies to
those two sides of the market and it's
also been kind of a an important problem
in the popular business press around
like you know companies that spend tons
of money to rapidly grow and how
rational that kind of spending is and
this is an attempt to kind of like put a
little theory around that yeah so that's
the main motivation for this so so
basically we'll be looking at two sided
markets that are kind of facilitated by
a platform so we'll be taking the
perspective of the platform in terms of
whistle we'll be looking at a platform
that want to wants to maximize its
discounted profit over to infinite
horizon so you know my personal
experience in the Sarat space is like an
ride-sharing so I'll be using a lot of
examples from that but it's a pretty
generic model so it applies in principle
to things like Airbnb where you have
people renting rooms and people yeah
it's a two-sided market for room is
there something like Amazon's
FBA marketplace or labor markets like
TaskRabbit etc but they'll all have the
characteristic that there's a supply
side a demand side a platform that
facilitates like transactions between
the supply and demand side
and that plant platform what we'll
assume in this work is that it controls
the prices and wages the price is paid
by buyers on the platform and the wages
paid to sellers but it has the option to
kind of like lower the price to demand
and increase the wage - to supply on the
pass apply side - even even at expense
of losing money to grow to grow the
market yeah so again like the kind of
main motivation this is that like growth
is typically subsidized and these
businesses so certainly in the rideshare
space were somewhat famous for like the
amount of subsidies that we offer and on
and into grow markets and so like these
subsidies are in the form of actually
just base prices that we offer the wages
that we set for drivers coupons other
incentives driver driver incentives etc
so promotions can subsidies can take a
number of forms but we'll just in a
stylized sense represent this as like
prices for supply and demand so the kind
of key questions we're going to look at
is like whether to subsidize growth over
time and if so how much to subsidize
growth so how much subsidy is really
necessary in these kind of markets and
and what and also like what is that
subsidy trajectory that optimal subsidy
trajectory look like over time and then
another important issue that we look at
here is like it's a two-sided market so
we're gonna look at whether how you
should balance those subsidies between
the supply and demand side so one of the
main results of the work is that there
is kind of a pretty clean result on how
you should balance the growth of the
supply and demand side of the market and
that's you know that's something we
definitely worry a lot about in in the
rideshare space is like what which side
is most important to subsidize and then
also like when should subsidies stop so
at what point do these platforms get to
enough scale where you can stop
subsidizing and start generating profits
so it's also kind of related this
phenomena this is like a pop business
book called blitzscaling on this idea
that like this is like a sort of generic
strategy for building a valuable company
which is that spend an enormous amount
of money over a short period of
time to sort of like bring that business
the scale and then that you know is sort
of the you know the sort of the most
profitable growth strategy and to a
certain extent not to give away the
punchline but like what we find in this
paper is they like rapid growth is
pretty generically at least under our
model like a rational strategy in these
two-sided markets cases and that's true
for both sort of increasing returns to
scale markets and decreasing returns to
scale markets so it's kind of you know
in some sense it's a stylized
confirmation of some of this stuff that
you see in the actual business world so
just here are some related literature so
it's related to pricing and two-sided
markets but kind of the big difference
is that we are taking them a little bit
more of a macro perspective and looking
at like pricing evolving over time as
the market grows so not so much the sort
of tactical dynamic pricing of supply
and demand on an operational level but
more the strategic pricing of like when
you launch a service and and it's a you
know like should you subsidize it early
on should those subsidies die out at
what point should you switch to taking
profit etc so it's much more of a sort
of macro model of two-sided pricing will
look at economies of scale and how those
affect the growth decision and that's
related to working like market thickness
in ride-sharing so the will have a more
kind of aggregate model of these
economies of scale but but there's some
literature around that you know in a
certain way it's rittle ated to like
macroeconomic growth at least kind of
stylistically so like our market it's
going to look like there's a supply a
stock of supply a stock of demand those
two things come together to produce
outputs in a two sided market that looks
a lot like sort of you have a stock of
labor you have a stock of capital those
two to combine to produce output in a
macro model so it has some relationship
to that at least in terms of the
modeling setup but the objectives are
very different
and so we're looking at profit
maximization for a platform this is
looking more like surplus maximization
and and it's it's fundamentally a
control theory model so there's some you
know like just it's not fancy control
theory but it is alright so here's the
outline so I'll go through the model
setup and this takes a little bit of
time because there's kind of like
there's an output model for the market
there's a growth model for the supply
and demand side then there's the kind of
the formulation of the the platform's
decision and then one of the main things
we do in the analysis is this
reformulations of the model to reduce it
to a much simpler kind of single state
representation of the problem I'll show
you how that works so we can kind of
reduce this to a model where you only
have a scalar multitude shows and it's
and the decision is like how do how to
manage that scalar growth over time so
I'll show you how that works and once
you get that formulation out of the way
then we have the main findings which
I'll detail in a second okay so let's
start with the output model so again
this is a pretty aggregate model so we
sort of have we have two states which is
the stock of supply and the stock of
demand so I think the cleanest thing to
think about is this is like the number
of buyers and sellers in a two sided
market so how many buyers you have how
many sellers you have but it could be
something more general like you know
it's like looking the ride sharing
industry we tend to look at like the
number of app sessions that people open
up so how open are often are they
checking to look for a ride and how many
supply hours of driving do we have in
the market and which doesn't necessarily
correspond one-to-one to the number of
users but but it you know to anchor on
something think of this as like supply
is the number of sellers demand is the
number of buyers and so we're gonna have
a production function that describes the
output of the market as a function of
those stocks of supply and demand and
it's basically just a generic
homogeneous production function of
degree alpha and so alpha here
basically going to describe the returns
to scale so basically this is a
production function that you know if I
were to double let's say supply and
demand I get some increase in output
that would be more than double if alpha
was greater than 1 and less than double
if alpha was less than 1 so again like
two state variables supply and demand
kind of production function returns to
scale like kind of one of the big
assumptions we're making is that returns
the scale is going to be constant in the
model so it's a limitation but and this
cover is like several cases like so the
cobb-douglas function falls in this
class the constant elasticity of
substitution production function falls
in this class as long as the returns the
scale aren't too large and and we also
have that result for matching function
just this straightforward simple
matching function but we have to use a
get a little bit of a special case
analysis for that but but the results
will apply to all those
all right so let me just say in
ride-sharing like where this where
economies of scale might kick in so I
think that like the typical case people
think of in ride-sharing is more of an
increasing returns to scale case and
this is due to density so what happens
in ride-sharing is initially when you
offer service in a city it's pretty
sparse like the number of drivers and
riders in the market is is like very
spread out as a result of that like when
somebody requests a ride it's a long
it's a long the closest available car is
usually far away that means that car has
to spend a lot of time picking that
passenger up and that means that the
drivers can't produce that many trips
per unit of supply but what happens as
you get more and more activity in the
market so it gets more and more dense
then the nearest available car is much
closer on average that means they spend
much less time picking up that means
they can get more trips done per unit
time and so you tend to see in this kind
of setup like as you get more and more
gross that you get like more and more
efficiency out of the supply and so
that's an increasing returns kind of
case and that's that's the thing that
would in the early days of ride-sharing
there's this famous uber napkin diagram
which apparently Travis kalanick and
Garrett camp who founded the company
were sketched out in some coffee shop in
Paris or something when they were
thinking of the company which is which
which is basically represents as a
virtuous cycle we're kind of like more
demand leads to more density more
density leads to more efficiency that
leads to lower cost that leads to lower
prices lower prices mean more demand and
you get in this virtuous cycle and some
more spiffed up version of this was
appeared in ubers I nine statement when
they filed for an IPO kind of explaining
why they have these Network economies of
scale and things like that
so this kind of thinking is pretty
deeply embedded in how rideshare
companies think about their business
so that's kind of a limitation of the
model and part of the reason we look at
increasing and decreasing returns is to
try to like I mean it's yeah it's
simpler think of think of economy as the
returns the scale is being constant and
also just to think of it as like yeah
let me let me just show you the other
case is that there isn't it this is
probably less well understood but there
can be decreasing returns to scale and
ridesharing because like once typically
like when you offer service in a city
and it gets to the point where you've
already saturated sort of a busy the
central core of the city then the growth
tends to take place by pushing the
service coverage region into like the
outskirts of the city and into the
suburbs and blah blah blah and so if
growth takes place by expanding the
coverage into these less densely
populated areas that can actually lead
to a decrease in this density which can
lead to sort of a decrease in efficiency
and therefore like a you know like
decreasing returns to scale as you grow
the business so kind of like the early
stage model rideshare is like more and
more activity in the same region the
later stage model is kind of expanding
the region to the hinterlands of blah
blah and then things can get more
inefficient so we have twice ten now you
have it much bigger difference between
so finely mono many people gonna be
hiding there yeah yeah yeah and there is
I mean that that function is a function
of both supply into answer like if you
double everything you'll get just that
scalar return to scale output but if you
change the ratio of supply to demand
that can also affect the output if you
don't change the right you know
sometimes they recover anymore value
drivers yeah yeah yeah then one of the
things we look at it's like exactly the
issue of like whether what is the
balance here all right so that is that
is the production model so that is like
the parsimonious kind of high-level
model of like how production takes place
in this two-sided market the other thing
we had to layer on top of that is like
how supply and demand grows so how how
the platform actually attracts more
users on both the supply and demand side
and so this the model is fundamentally
driven by these two things so that we
have assumed growth rates of supply and
demand so the number of users on the
supply and demand side grows due to two
main effects so when is this adoption
effect which is proportional to the
surplus that the two sides receive so
basically what we're assuming that is
like we deliver more surplus the buyers
will get more buyers if we deliver more
surplus the sellers will get more
sellers so there's some growth related
to how much surplus we're delivering to
them and then the other thing we're
gonna assume is there's this attrition
effect which basically boils down to
like exogenously users of the platform
just drop off so you know we can recruit
a driver they'll drive for six months or
so but maybe you know they're doing that
in between jobs and they find a some
other job and then they stop driving for
us or a user you know is using
ride-sharing for a certain they move out
of the city they buy a car something
else that causes them to just drop out
of the service so this is what sort of
the surplus part of it looks like so
well I don't know why this is getting
cut off
spoken like a true supper engine
[Music]
do do you fullscreen yeah that's what I
was doing
yeah there it goes always works right
turning it on and off okay thank you
okay all right so so these are the kind
of main components for the surplus so
we'll assume each seller has a cost to
provide a trance and then output we're
gonna call transactions so think of it
as rides or you know buying and selling
something so each seller has a cost see
if we're providing a transaction each
buyer has a utility v4 receiving the
output of a transaction the platform is
gonna set prices for both the supply and
demand and so this is the price that
that we pay to a seller and this is the
price that we charge to a buyer and so
the surplus is basically but the thing
is like the surplus isn't this
difference so like for the suppliers if
there is a transaction now get surplus
of P of s minus C so what we pay them -
their cost but they only get that
surplus if we facilitate a transaction
and so if you want to think of it as
this is the surplus per seller in the
market so if we have a great marketplace
that would just deliver outstanding
value if they're a transaction took
place but no transactions take place
then we don't we're not delivering any
surplus
so and there's a similar thing on the
pirate buying side so the utility we we
get every buyer every buyer gets in the
market is the utility of a transaction
times the number of transactions divided
by how many buyers there are in the
market
guess the sly processes but like first
why think of like the payment curve ride
and not just think of how much I pay
drivers and expectation what's the
monthly implied monthly wage of drivers
and kind of like in the background stick
like should I think of Google quitting
drivers as different than than Amazon a
Walmart booting workers well the first
one was like why don't you think of it
as just yeah I mean it's good of a model
where you're just paying every supplier
in the market basically a certain amount
whether transactions happen or not you
could do that
but I'm trying to model the situation
where like yeah like where yeah but it's
just an assumption on the model that
like we you know it's like we said we
set a price that we pay if a transaction
takes place but we don't necessarily
like transactions so that would that
would be different
yeah so that's that's the kind of
utility model and then kind of what
we're gonna assume about growth here is
that the growth of supply and demand so
that we just have a different
differential equation for this is
proportional to you know this surplus
term and then this is the attrition term
so basically the way to interpret these
attrition terms is basically 1 over the
beta 0 is the average lifetime of a kind
of a supplier or supplier on the network
we'll assume they're these coefficients
on these utilities that kind of
determine how much every dollar of
utility that we generate how much does
that contribute to the to the growth and
actually if you take the reciprocal of
those coefficients they have the
interpretation of adoption cost though
the way to think of it it's like if I
want to acquire a new unit of supply or
demand I have to play pay 1 over beta I
have to generate 1 over beta and surplus
to kind of get that growth of one more
unit of demand so that's that's really
the interpretation of those
because I was thinking in terms the
attrition terminated reservations once I
was out
no I mean principal we could set those
things to zero yeah
you'll see we have a notion of balance
that kind of requires that term so let
me Olivia
I haven't actually thought about that
but you could certainly let that get
arbitrarily small and everything would
work out
yes so those are the fundamental growth
equations I would say just in full
disclosure that probably this would like
them limiting sort of them maybe the
more unrealistic part of the model that
we assume that you know so basically
what this says if we generate an
arbitrary large amount of surplus we can
grow as fast as we want and both supply
and demand
and that moreover that that growth is
linear and that surplus assuming that
the average lifetime is independent okay
yeah so that's yeah so that's kind of
like an exogenous lifetime so yeah
you're right in the sense that like
people might but but in some sense this
thing capture it's like if we were
delivering really low utility to
suppliers that utility actually could be
negative for example that would cause
them to just like abandon the platform
so in some sense we're trying to
decompose sort of exhaustion is you know
dropping out due to things that we do
not not controlling and then that
surplus related either growth or kind of
decline based on the surplus
okay so the platform what does the
platform do so it controls the prices
for supply and demand and it has the
choice at any point in time - it gives
it such the price that is paying for a
transaction higher than the wage
it'll be taking profit so we'll be
making profit on every transaction and
if it sets the wage higher than the
price then it'll be subsidizing the
market so in principle it could set you
know could give away the product and pay
suppliers really high wages that would
create a ton of surplus on both sides of
the market but it would cost the
platform money so the platform's
objective will be to maximize its total
discounted profit over an infinite
horizon
we're profit at anytime as the price
minus the wage times how many
transactions are taking place so that
leads to this infinite horizon
formulation so this is what the model
looks like so this is the infinite this
kind of total profit that the platform
makes these are the two growth equations
we assume there's some initial condition
of supply and demand we start with some
positive amount of supply and demand and
then the problem is to kind of like find
the optimal price path given this
initial condition that maximizes that
discounted profit
now yes interpret the G which is the
number of friends prices so I assume
that if we change the prices now they
never transaction yeah
that's a great point yeah so it's not
really it's a little bit slippery in
that sense so it sort of says that like
the transactions will take place the way
that price affects things is that I'll
get an immediate set of transactions
regardless of the price that I charge
but then if I let's say if I charge a
really really high price here that'll
create a very negative oh sorry that's
the supply side if I if I pay a very low
wage here that'll generate negative
surplus and I'll have you know I'll get
a drop in the number of suppliers yeah
so it's it's sort of like the prices
effect like the trajectory so I can tank
the number of users I have by charging
prices that are extreme that it won't
affect sort of the instantaneous like so
it's kind of the demand functions in
there but not
okay so let me show you know that in
itself it's not it's not a horrendously
difficult problem but it's like there's
a way to simplify this which is like
super useful and understanding what's
going on here and so so one of our main
results here is that that two-state
problem with a supply and demand state
and two control variables which are like
supply and demand prices can be reduced
to a single dimensional problem we're
the only state is this market size
variable X and the way to interpret this
is X is like the value the total value
of the supply stock where supply and
demand because like this one over beta
is sort of like the acquisition cost for
a supply and the acquisition costs for
demand so take how much supply and
demand I have I multiplied by the
acquisition cost and then that gives me
sort of like in the essence it's like
how much money I've spent building up
the market to this particular size X so
this thing has units of dollars and then
the division between supply and demand
is described by this variable gamma
which is just what fraction of this
total market value is allocated between
this to the supply side so if this is 0
like all the values in the demand side I
don't have any I don't have any
suppliers and if that value is 1 like
all the value is concentrated in the
supply side and I don't have any any
buyers
and this sort of I mean I'm kind of but
but the way we show this is you can
actually show that under them under this
model here like and it's kind of related
to what you were just saying about like
you can make these instantaneous like
impulse price shocks that will shift the
balance of from supply to demand and
preserve but preserve this total this
total value and those price shocks will
be kind of costless in the sense that
like so the way to think of this is I
could I could charge riders in my
network all of a sudden a really high
price for rides they could take all that
cash that I generate it from them
instantaneously plow it into paying the
drivers big subsidies that would
decrease the number of riders I have in
the network increase the number of
drivers but that exchange of value would
wouldn't cost me anything because I'd
just be like pulling value out of one
side and dumping it into the other side
it's very stylized I know but it sort of
represents but I think it's sort of oh
yeah oh yeah I'll show you a second like
the growth rate itself will depend on
these two things but the point is that
like this is the state like I can't
change this I can't change the fact that
I have this much invested in the market
I can't change this unless all of a
sudden I don't I actually dump money
into the market
these are the coefficients on the on the
surplus part of it
yeah now this is on the the adoption
part of it the surplus of the surplus
part of it
right so so right and again like X has
has the interpretation of
yeah yeah so beta 1 are these
coefficients and again like 1 over beta
when you play with the prices like you
said it right yeah yeah right
then I'm reducing the growth rate to the
buyers increasing the growth rate to the
sellers yep not G the value sorry yes so
the thing that I keep constant is is
this thing yeah but so here the heavy
condition on homes may be the return of
the prices to control that onyx of how
fast you can change prices
yeah so that that decomposition kind of
assumes that I can make these impulse
price changes yeah exactly
now in reality actually I'll show you
the actual policies don't necessarily
require that so it's kind of like a
little bit of a modeling artifact but so
it turns out actually if you have like
like if this trajectory of market size
is smooth and the corresponding prices
will be smooth
you want but at the same time the model
at least the unconstrained with no
constraint on prices could allow you to
take a jump in market size by just
injecting an enormous amount amount he
had an impulse amount of money into the
market to kind of take those two levels
of supply and demand you know just make
a jump I jump change in those two levels
okay so one of the nice things about
this model is it lets you at least this
transformation it lets you unambiguously
talk about like faster and slower growth
because now we boiled down this issue of
like market rather than we've boiled it
down to like the market size is the
single measure that matters in terms of
like the size of them how big the market
is and so like you can say a growth path
like you know x1 is a faster growth path
than x2 at the size of the market at all
times T is like larger than the size of
this you know this growth
and yeah and you can talk about like the
fastest possible growth paths would be
this like jump which would let's say
take you from this initial size to this
terminal size in just one step that
could be achieved with just injecting
just an impulse of spending but more
generally like so it has this nice
interpretation of size as a single
dimensional thing that you can keep
track of and the talk meaningfully about
like slow growth fast growth etc so
that's one of the nice things about it
yeah and so under this size and balance
reef formulation like the production
function can be transformed into a
function of X and gamma which looks like
this there's some regularity conditions
on the function H that you have to
impose but they're not that restrictive
so
and the production functions that I
showed you earlier satisfy those
conditions okay so this is what the
reformulated problem looks like in this
size and balanced formulation so now
again like we have a single state
variable X we have now two controls like
well one control is this balanced choice
like how do we split the value of the
market the size of the market between
supply and demand and then this pie
which is just the difference between the
demand and supply price and then we can
also add like constraints on the growth
path so in this part like one of the
things we've kind of modified in the
work lately is to think about putting
actual constraints on the growth path
itself and let me just give you some
examples and these kind of represent
some features that I think are missing
from the initial formulation so so one
is you could have a finite market size
so you could say that like X grows but
there's some like maximum value that it
reaches because at that point you can't
get the market any larger than that so
you could have like a finite upper bound
on X another one is you know there's
this linear kind of growth assumption in
the model you could you could say that
kind of a rough cut way of saying that
subsidies saturate there's a saturation
effect with subsidies is to say that the
relative growth growth rate at any time
is bounded by some upper bound so I can
grow the market at a certain rate but
beyond that rate additional subsidies
don't really like resulting in faster
growth
and then my favorite is the funding
constraint which is basically you could
say that the way you you grow a market
is there's you you have a subsidies that
you're spending to maybe grow the market
at time T those subsidies are bounded by
some multiple of the size of the market
so the way to think of this is like you
know I've got to go back to my private
investors like soft bank and get more
money and and what they look at is well
how big is your market right now so if
you if you grow your market to a certain
size we'll give you more money and then
you can keep trying to grow it further
than that so things like this are kind
of things that would represent like
frictions on growth etc but they're
pretty easy to handle so individual
matches become more valuable yeah the
value of the market but this doesn't
happen in your model because the market
values just determined by the amount of
my demand and the acquisition maybe
maybe it's the terminology market value
that's misleading because I know what
you're like it's true that like if I
have if I have a bear market so my
market size is larger my definition and
I take you know and I plug that into the
production function like I will in the
increasing returns case I will get more
output in a larger market than a smaller
market and if you look at the discounted
profit it depends on that output so in
that sense like you know but it's just
more a terminology like it's it
represents kind of the current like the
weight I think of it's like the current
value invested in the market kind of in
some sense it's like you delivered the
surplus to suppliers and buyers that
cause them to to adopt the service
you've gotten that up to a certain level
actually there's a more technical way to
see it which is actually that the policy
would allow you to take that market size
and through these same kind of price
shocks basically liquidate that and you
could instantaneously earn X dollars
but then you be the game would be over I
mean it so so you can get to X and
liquidate it and get X dollars and so
it's like I could liquidate the market
at that point and get X dollars but it
but you're absolutely right in the sense
that it may be more profitable to
operate the market and collect those
discounted profits as a result of having
gotten to that scale and it and X does
not represent that discounted profit
potential it's yeah it's not a good term
ok so the main one of the main findings
is the market balance so it turns out
that for any market size X of T there's
a unique optimal market balance which we
call gamma star which is just a function
of the market size and it's determined
by this implicit function but it's not
not too complicated and moreover that
optimal mark market balance is monotone
in the size so basically what it means
is like you know and and and what
determines the direction of the
monotonicity whether you're going from
like us
so gamma think you can think of it as
like how supply heavy versus demand
heavy as the market so gamin zero means
it's very demand heavy like there's
nothing
none of the market value is contained in
the supply side so it could be that like
you you start with a very supply a
demand heavy market and it grows to a
supply of you market or it could go the
other way around but it's that
directional change and the balance is
affected by the returns the scale and
the strength of these attrition and
adoption effects so I'll show you that
in a second but the other the other
interesting thing about this is that
this implies that the only optimal once
you know that X uniquely determines
gamma like you're all the way you're all
the way down to just the only decision
that the firm has to make is what growth
reject reject area wants so basically
with this result you basically boil the
problem boils down to just choosing the
path X of T because the thing is like
once you choose X of T that determines
gamma a T of T once you have X of T and
gamma of T that actually determines like
what prices you need to charge to
realize those X's and and so
like then the whole thing kind of like
falls out so the interesting thing about
this is just this the firm's optimal
decision reduces to just choosing which
growth path it wants
so yeah and here's the balance result
I'll just show essentially this is like
a trade-off between choosing a balance
which is minimizes the attrition that
you're gonna experience versus choosing
a balance which maximizes the output
that you're gonna achieve so if you look
at that growth equation those are the
two things that drive it the attrition
effect kind of ending and the output
effect and there's an output maximizing
balance which maximizes like the output
term and then there's a balance which
minimizes the attrition and that and we
call that like the durability maximizing
balance and that boils down to just like
keeping all the market size in the
supply side or keeping all of it in the
demand side whichever kind of has in
some sense like the longest lifetime
and the idea is that the returns the
scale effect this so like if you look at
a increasing returns market when the
market is very small like output
relative to size is very small because
it's it's a decrease it's an increasing
returns market so it's like it's not
very efficient at small scale and
therefore the optimal balance is to kind
of maximize durability and then as the
market grows then it approaches the
output maximizing balance because like
output then and the increasing returns
case output gets very large relative to
the size of the market and that becomes
the more dominant factor in the new
growth
it's sort of the reverse case in the
decreasing returns market so in
decreasing returns its its output
relative to sizes is very high when it's
the market small and you you choose the
output maximizing balance and then as it
grows output starts to get less
efficient and the attrition thing
becomes the more important factor and
then it then it kind of goes to the
durability maximizing balance
so yeah so that's that's how those two
things
okay so you can also find there's a
stationary solution so if you write down
the maximum principle conditions for
this problem you get like a definition
of a stationary market size
so it turns out in the ink increasing
returns to scale that's just a saddle
point of the optimization problem but
the decreasing returns to scale like
this stationary solution is kind of the
long-run optimal market size so so this
so we are able to characterize what's
like what sort of the at what what point
do you stop growing in a decreasing
returns market and just stay put and
kind of like generate profits at that
level for infinity
it also kind of this is another result
but it determines a breakpoint on when
fast and slow growth is optimal
all right so and then the other major
finding here is that for both the
increasing and decreasing returns to
scale market as long as the final market
size is sort of like viable and what I
mean by that is it's like the discounted
profits you earn by getting to this
terminal size are sufficient to warrant
the cost of growing to that size so it's
like it makes economic sense to get to
that size as long as that's true then
for both these cases it turns out the
faster you get there the better
so in the increasing returns case that
could be you know you trying to get to
some upper bound and then the faster to
get there the better in the decreasing
returns cases trying to get to the
stationary sighs yeah so this is a this
is a monopoly model and I should have
pointed that out earlier so yeah yeah
yeah yeah exactly yeah
yeah so we we have an extension we're
working on a kind of oligopoly model but
I would just say that you know it's
almost more surprising in the monotony
Nopalea case because in a oligopoly
model you'd think there'd be much more
of an incentive to kind of race to get
to this get to scale first so this kind
of shows that even in a monopoly where
you don't necessarily have to prevent
entry of a competitor or kind of squeeze
them out it's still optimal to grow fast
yeah yeah so maybe in the interest of
time I'll skip that but this is just
kind of formalizing what it means to
grow fast so in the increasing returns
case actually the increasing returns
case if there's no upper bound on the
size the problem is actually unbounded
so it's kind of a not super interesting
in that case but if there's a upper
bound on the market size then you know
if there's no constraint on the growth
path then then an impulse jump just to
get or at that size is optimal and if
there is some kind of bounded growth
rate due to like one of those funding
constraints or things of that sort you
pick the fastest path that's compatible
with that constraint you could spend
more right now but it would buy you less
growth then based on how much you've
been spending right now right because
that seems like it works great for the
common good sigh so over a short period
of time yeah it's in a sense it's it's
Markovian how much growth you get for
certain amount of money is how much
you've been spending over the last
correct yeah so you're thinking of if
there's like a global budget constraint
on on subsidies for example so like I
just hand you a billion dollars but if
you blow through it in the first you
know they're gonna have lots later on so
you can't spend as much caution a lot of
usage on that one day but I don't think
that it's like a sustainable
market size increase like if I'd spent
that 1 billion over one week I mentioned
I would have been able to to reach more
people yeah yeah no so this model if you
like I mean look at look at it like you
know whether it's a burst of acquisition
over a short period of time or sort of
like a trickle of acquisition over a
longer period of time
does it matter in terms of like yeah
once you've acquired them you acquired
them it doesn't matter like how you
acquire them like that would be outside
the bottle
yeah so this is kind of like the main
right so this is just detailing what
what it means to grow faster in
decreasing returns again like the
terminal sighs there's a stationary
terminal size and if you have no
constraints on growth then the quick the
best thing to do is just jump right to
that terminal size through it like an
impulsive spending and if you have
constraints then the thing is to choose
the fastest growth path
so this is maybe a little bit more
surprising than the increasing returns
case because like in decreasing returns
you can grow without subsidies
so it's always profitable to grow
because you don't have to spend money to
grow because it's efficient early on so
you don't have to spend money but at the
same time not subsidizing markets means
you grow slowly and that means you don't
get to this like large size that
generates these attractive profits and
it's still better to kind of like spend
to get to that size quickly because you
pull those profits forward in time so
it's a bit counterintuitive is that with
decreasing returns you would expect that
the marginal returns to spending
diminish very quickly
yeah well the marginal turn returns to
acquiring acquiring more size diminish
and that's why that's why they flatten
out and that's why you get to this X
star and things like that but the point
is like it's still worth getting to that
X star and if you're gonna you know yeah
let me show you so that a numerical
example this is like yeah this is the
decreasing returns case so that's the
thing like you could not subsidize the
market zero subsidy the market will grow
you'll hit the yellow kid you know
you'll hit the terminal size and stay
there but the discounted value of that
this kind of profit associated with that
growth path is less than the discounted
profit associated with a path that
subsidizes to get to that point earlier
so yeah
I think look in your model acquiring a
million customers over till periods is
just as expensive as acquiring them
right right that's the linearity
assumption so that that's the thing I
was saying is kind of the Achilles heel
its model in a certain sense and that's
why I was putting that one that one
thing is kind of a way to fudge that
which is to say that like the rate of
growth so how rapidly you can grow the
you know you can grow the market let's
say at most 10% per per unit time you
know so that that's a way of kind of
putting that kind of like limit ons on
how fast an growth that's a very crude
form of concavity yeah yes yeah yeah yes
yeah but I think you may even known the
increasing returns you'd have the same
problem because yeah it would get more
and more costly to even do a fast yeah
okay so yeah let me just wrap up so this
let me let me just show with this last
thing so in this is the increasing
returns market so this this just shows
that like an increasing return zero
subsidy because it's like very
inefficient at low scale actually can
lead to a decline in size a low subsidy
may actually have like a negative profit
because like it's so costly to kind of
like you know you're operating at this
low scale for such a long period of time
that's costly whereas like something a
much more rapid subsidy actually
produces a positive like value so it's
interesting that in both cases that
happens okay right and we do have
results on the matching function which
are very consistent and and then the
main thing is again like fast growth is
optimal the optimal balance is different
in a sense that's always sort of like
supply equals demand is the optimal
balance
okay so just in summary yeah so I think
the contributions here I think it's an
interesting like simplification of this
I mean I find it very useful to just
like think of this as a one-dimensional
like growth thing it's like market size
what should that market size trajectory
look like I think that's a nice
simplification of it and and really that
the really this boils down to this whole
optimal growth problem really at least
under this framework boils down to just
choosing this optimal size trajectory so
it's kind of a nice reduction of
complexity for this problem and then you
know I think this balance result is
interesting and sure in terms of showing
the effect of attrition and adoption and
how those change as the market evolves
and gets goes from small to large and
then just sort of like you know at least
some theoretical confirmation of this
like rapid growth has a sort of an
optimal strategy regardless of whether
they're increasing or decreasing mature
that I mentioned we have some ongoing
work on oligopoly version sort of the
same theme except the kind of the the
sizes that result when you kind of in
equilibrium when competitor is kind of
like simultaneously try to grow those
market sizes are bigger than the market
size that of Monopoly would choose so
that's the main competitive affected
their lower profit larger size markets
that evolve when you have competitors
then comparative
okay thank you very much home sensitive
to high school what do you think this is
the constant attendant for which one
it's not constant return what do you
mean oh yeah I mean yeah I mean yeah
it's it's a limitation I mean I guess
the way I would look at it as I'd kind
of say like it's like again like just
for my industry like right cheering I
would tend to think of it it's like this
increasing returns is a good model of
sort of early early stage growth market
and you know it's it's more question of
like and the decreasing returns probably
a reasonable model of later stage growth
just I think it would get complicated to
have a model but maybe it's you know I
think a lot of I mean a lot of the
simplicity is driven by that I mean that
assumption and I think it's not
realistic
in either case that like that returns
the scale would stay constant over large
changes in them in the market size
there's just like especially the
increasing returns case like you can't
have increasing returns forever and
that's why that problem is unbounded it
like if you don't put any constraint on
it because it's like it's not sensible
it's not physically sensible to have
that have that
can make the same arguments momo-chan
Ali without without reliable attempts to
scale but you're saying if it's worth to
get to some market size it's worth
getting I mean a camp that can't always
be true because it depends on I mean all
things being equal yeah it's like you
know if there's some like pot of rain
pot of gold at the end of the rainbow
and it's like you know you'd rather get
that like you know now rather than five
years from now but the it's the question
of like how much does it cost you to get
to that and and that's why the
increasing decreasing returns is the
interesting because like you don't need
to spend money to get to that pot of
gold I mean you don't need to spend
money to ramp up to that getting those
just paint this cause of acquisition the
it's can be destroyed from the value of
the market so growing it is just paying
the costs or getting to the scale and it
can be more valuable available but
getting there is always this axe no it's
that's not true because like as you like
if you take a slower growth strategy
well actually the one of the main
factors is as you take a slower growth
strategy you're subject to you're
subjecting yourself to this like
attrition of fact right so you're
pumping money into acquire these riders
and drivers but then you're also losing
them over time so I think like a lot of
the thing driving this is that if you
just acquire them all at once like
you're not exposing yourself to that
kind of you know that drag of like
constantly losing them like so the
reason it takes longer when you kind of
like and maybe this was an inquiry is
about Zuri like said when he asked about
zero attrition maybe in that case it's
the same
yeah but but it would still be slower so
it would like the the discounted value
of like infinite and you know the you
know the terminal value of getting to
that finite markets the stationary
market size would be put off like if you
did I don't know I have to look at the
case without attrition and see maybe it
still be true in that case of okay I'm
taking control here anyway twelve
minutes passed
thank you very much
[Applause]